partager avec vous les initiatives de
solidarité en pologne en moldavie ou
encore en roumanie et en france comment
sont ils accueillis quels sont leurs
besoins comment l'europe peut-elle faire
face à un afflux de réfugiés toujours
plus importants nous irons à la
frontière ukrainienne du côté de la
pologne et de la moldavie retrouver nos
envoyés spéciaux sur le terrain et nous
en parlons ce soir avec nos invités
céline schmitt est avec nos bonsoir vous
êtes porte parole du haut commissariat
de l'onu pour les réfugiés et bienvenue
dans cette émission spéciale en face de
vous il reina carpa bonsoir écrivaine
scénariste et musicienne ukrainienne
bienvenue à vous également en fait pitié
et également avec nous bon soir à vous
ce médecin humanitaire en l'occurrence à
l'eau ssm france union des organisations
de secours et soins médicaux bienvenue
également un raphaël pitié à bonjour
roma roma aux oui le bon soir stéphanie
antoine on attend aussi vos questions
vos réactions sur les réseaux sociaux
pendant sept heures d'émission nous
relaierons évidemment certains de vos
commentaires à l'antenne aurait tout de
suite justement en pologne retrouver
notre envoyé spécial emmanuel chasse des
manuels plus de la moitié des ukrainiens
qui ont fui le pays arrive en pologne
c'est le premier pays d'accueil vous
assistez à un élan de solidarité sur
place c'est cela
oui tout à fait la pologne vraiment qui
accueille qui a accueilli jusqu'à ce
jour depuis le 24 février plus de 1,7
million d'ukrainiens parfois plus de
cent mille personnes par jour à médical
où je me trouvais un peu plus tôt et
bien c'était vingt mille personnes par
jour ces derniers jours d'aidé après
l'agression russe en ukraine et bien il
ya eu toute cette population qui qui
s'est dirigé vers la colonne et
l'accueil effectivement a été celui
d'une grande solidarité et du côté
citoyen il ya énormément de polonais qui
ont ouvert leur maison qui héberge
désormais des ukrainiens il faut savoir
qui est aussi une forte communauté
ukrainienne a déjà bien avant cette
agression russe en ukraine une forte
communauté ukrainienne ici en pologne où
près de deux millions de personnes donc
ce qu'on a assisté aux premières
semaines pendant les premières semaines
ça a été
les gens qui sont venus rejoindre leur
famille mais évidemment un plus grande
échelle issus des initiatives comme
réquisitionner les écoles ici dans cette
région frontalière afin de permettre
d'établir des centres d'hébergement
d'urgence donc la colonne très fortement
mobilisée pour pour accueillir ces
millions de personnes qui arrivent
chaque jour qui continuaient d'arriver
qui continuent d'arriver chaque jour à
ces postes frontières on attendait
également les ong sont elles arrivées
sur place
elles commencent à arriver et ce sont de
plus en plus présentes vous voyez
dernièrement il ya des pompiers ce sont
des pompiers volontaires français ils se
trouvent sur plusieurs postes frontière
le long de la frontière il ya des
associations des ong qui sont
représentées de tous les pays des ong
américaine irlandaise indienne chinoise
britannique qui se déplacent l'insolent
pardon les om lille om le l'office
internationale pour les migrations est
également présent c'étaient des semaines
placent alors elle a été un peu lente à
se mettre en place aujourd'hui à medica
qui se trouve à environ 40 kilomètres
d'ici et bien les nations unies sont
arrivés donc c'est presque trois
semaines après le début de cet exode
massif de réfugiés venus d'ukraine donc
une aide qui est présent qui s'organise
qui est encore en fait en plein
tâtonnements alors que les gens
continuent d'arriver par milliers tous
les jours ici en pologne merci emmanuel
emmanuel chain zodiac de la frontière
polonaise céline schmitt 100000
ukrainien de plus par jour qui fuient le
pays on voit que les nations unies sont
arrivés viennent d'arriver en pologne ce
sont principalement des femmes et des
enfants et des personnes avec des
handicaps c'est ça oui la majorité des
réfugiés qui arrivent sont effectivement
des femmes et des enfants des personnes
qui vulnérables comme des personnes
âgées mais aussi des enfants non
accompagnés
nous le fc on est on est présent en
pologne et dans les autres pays voisins
depuis de nombreuses années on avait
déjà des bureaux sur place mais
effectivement on a dû renforcer nos
équipes pour répondre à cette nouvelle
situation d'urgence pour soutenir les
autorités pour coordonner aussi la
réponse humanitaire
et un des sujets qu'on sur lesquels on
travaille c'est effectivement on a
alerté sur le besoin de protection des
femmes qui sont plus à risque de
violence sur les routes de l'exil mais
aussi des enfants et notamment des
enfants non accompagnés
enfin d'un accomagné les hommes en fait
entre 18 et 60 ans doivent rester en
ukraine c'est la raison pour laquelle on
il ya peu d'hommes et il ya des
séparations familiales qui se passe du
coup juste de l'autre côté de la
frontière et mes collègues sur place me
le disait là et dans d'autres pays
effectivement qu'ils voyaient parfois
juste de l'autre côté de la frontière
des familles qui étaient séparés ou les
maris déposer leurs épouses leurs
enfants et ensuite les familles prend
les femmes les enfants traversent choqué
aussi traumatisé et du coup le besoin
aussi d'apporter une attention
particulière sur le besoin de soutien et
de soutien psychologique
les réfugiés le craignant une protection
temporaire en europe c'est une sorte de
statut favorable oui c'est cette
protection temporaire qui a été activé
il ya maintenant plusieurs jours déjà
pour la première fois depuis 2001
lorsque la directive sur la protection
temporaire a été adopté c'est
effectivement une très bonne chose et ça
permet aux réfugiés qui viennent du crem
d'avoir accès à une protection plus
rapide sans passer par la demande
individuelle d'asile donc effectivement
c'est très bien parce que ça leur permet
d'avoir accès à une protection sociale
selon les pays aussi la possibilité de
travailler et donc maintenant il faut
que ça se mette en place effectivement
dans les différents pays européens mais
c'est c'est une très bonne chose qu'ils
aient cette protection temporaire
raphaël pythie on était en pologne
quelques instants vous êtes rendu
justement dans ce pays vous avez vu tuer
une mission en pologne qu'est-ce-qui
qu'est ce qui vous a marqué qu'est ce
que vous retenez de cette mission bien
c'est justement à des organisations on
lit les images que vous voyez ci sont
celles que j'ai vu j'étais à medica au
niveau du poste frontière et j'étais
aussi dans le centre d'accueil ou dans 1
une foire exposition dé transformer en
centre d'accueil à peu près dix mille
personnes dans une pagaille monumentale
et c'est bien ça qui poserait un vrai
problème
il ya des conditions sanitaires qui ne
sont pas qu'ils sont épouvantables pour
tous en particulier le manque 2 le
manque de toilettes ne manque de doux
suffisant pour pour cette population une
désorganisation totale on a du mal à le
comprendre quand on sait que nous avons
au niveau
européen un centre qui s'appelle échos
qui est capable de coordonner l'ensemble
des protections civiles il ya une
capacité à mobiliser les protection
civile de tous les pays européens qui
pourraient se mobiliser pour apporter
tout ce dont ces populations a besoin
votre envoyé spécial de 10 est ce que
les ong sont arrivés à ce que les
associations sont arrivés mais il y à
des protections civiles qui sont en
place dans tous les pays que nous
pourrions mobilisée en force il y à des
hôpitaux mobiles il y à des centres
d'accueil sous tente il y a des moyens
qui sont énormes au niveau européen et
je ne comprends pas pourquoi cela ne se
met pas en place donc de gros problèmes
d'hébergement mais concernant le ce
périple ce trajet entre l'ukraine et
donc la pologne le pays voisin le pays
amis oui comment se passe ce trajet dans
quelles conditions alors soit c'est en
voiture et on les voit arriver à medica
ils arrivent en voiture et les époux
laisse à ce moment là les femmes les
enfants et c'est au niveau du poste
frontière soit ils sont venus à pied
soit ils sont venus en bus sans que tous
les moyens sont possibles et il traverse
depuis souvent à pied à ce mot là le
poste frontière pour venir donc être
pris en charge par les polonais ils
montent dans des bus qui sont là et ils
vont vers les centres d'hébergement
d'accueil qui sont prêtes à environ 20
km 2 de medica où ils sont accueillis
mais je vous dis dans un flux et reflux
constant très important il y avait
énormément de solidarité et ça c'est
vrai au point que l'on se pose la
question de savoir il ya énormément
d'associations qui distribuent de la
nourriture partout
il y a des dons qui arrivent il a des
vrais problèmes en ce qui concerne
justement ces stocks de nourriture
qu'ils sont là alors de temps en temps
voilà remet qui va chercher des défauts
des friandises et ses rails avec un
caddie se promène entre les gens pour
distribuer les friandises aux enfants
c'est un peu la pagaille c'est ça c'est
épouvantable et ça sent mauvais bien
évidemment manque de manque d'hygiène
c'est certain avec un flux et reflux
constants il y a deux types de
population la population qui veut rester
en pologne parce qu'elle a des amis de
la famille et cetera mais il ya ceux qui
veulent partir à l'étranger parce qu'ils
ont aussi de la famille et puis vous
avez les femmes et les enfants qui n'ont
rien et qui veulent rester là justement
pour être très proche de la frontière
pour pouvoir retrouver leur mari pourra
retourner en ukraine le plus rapidement
possible et rana car par vous êtes une
artiste un vous chantez dans un groupe
que vous êtes en france une partie de
votre famille et en ukraine ils
accueillent eux des ukrainiens oui parce
qu'ils ont il se trouve à l'ouest de
l'ukraine crm salle 2 petite ville
montagneuse donc mes paroles en petit
hôtel qui est surpeuplée maintenant avec
donc il ya trois chiens de chats pour le
moment il y en avait plus avant je crois
que ce que les gens ils partent et les
repas est donc là pour le moment oui mon
père il s'occupe d'eux le délai voilà
les transporter ma marque pour les
héberger les nourrir mais normalement
c'est l'action que tout le monde fait
pour pour ce moment si c'est vraiment un
grand moment de solidarité ne veut pas
fuir
ma mère me dit ok il ya le bombardement
dans notre jardin mais je fuis mais
parce que moi même bien sûr que je
proposais dès le début est par contre
mes amis qui s'étaient même pas ce que
moi ça fait des années que j'habitais
accueilli avant de déménager à paris et
donc meilleurs amis sont là acquis là
j'ai hébergé déjà la femme de mon
meilleur ami avec ses deux enfants on a
un berger aussi ma batteuse avec sa
fille de 13 ans et c'est vrai c'est
comment comment il se retrouve là bas
qu'est ce que c'est difficile de se
séparer de son mari et le pleure chaque
jour elles pleurent la nuit pour ne pas
nous sommes de thé et le disque mais
parce que sont les gens qui sont très
traumatisés très épuisés et le petit
garçon de 8 ans il a vu dans ma cuisine
une bouteille de vin la première chose
qu'il a dit dis donc c'est le cocktail
molotov se dit maintenant mais pas du
tout c'est autre chose c'est du jeu
roisin voilà et ses traumatismes les
enfants après la petite de 13 ans elle a
commencé son collège aujourd'hui nous on
avait dit est ce que ce sera stressant
pour toi et tout l est d après que je me
suis ce que je que j'ai arrivé à
montséret dans l'autre assure peuple et
rien ne me stresse broute là là vraiment
il arrive à faire des blagues mais c'est
vrai que c'est très traumatisant et en
un autre petit de 4 ans moindre bruit le
claquement de portière de voiture il se
plaque contre le seul parce que là il
ils comprennent pas il ya une autre la
petite de six ans elle est passée à côté
de notre dame et l'a demandé est ce que
notre dame à brûler parce que c'était là
missiles russes qui rentrait donc là
vraiment c'est toute la population toute
la génération qui aura ça dans normes
aimant difficile de s'occuper de ses
enfants traumatisés on va tout de suite
en moldavie maintenant retrouver notre
envoyé spécial au riad verdier oriane
vous êtes avec nous vous êtes à la
frontière ukrainienne côté moldavie la
moldavie on le sait est aussi très
mobilisés c'est le pays qui
proportionnellement à sa population
accueille le plus grand nombre de
réfugiés et c'est plutôt bien organisé
oui plus de trois cent mille réfugiés
ukrainiens ont passé la frontière
moldave cent mille sont restés en
moldavie ça représente plus de 4% de la
population moldave c'est donc énorme
pour ce pays qui est plutôt petit par
rapport à l'ukraine est donc une fois
qu'ils passent la frontière ils sont
très rapidement orientée vers des bus
certains partent directement vers la
roumanie vers bucarest où il ya ce
l'aéroport le plus proche de l'autre
côté de la frontière puisque l'espace
aérien moldave est fermé et certains et
bien viennent à la capitale chisinau la
capitale moldave pour être ensuite
placés dans des centres d'hébergement ou
rejoindre des amis car ici il ya
beaucoup d'ukrainiens qui connaissent
des moldaves puisque beaucoup nous le
rappellent ces deux nations sont frères
ils ont vécu beaucoup de choses
historiquement ensemble ils parlent la
même langue
en tout cas une des même langue le russe
comment quelle est la réaction des
moldaves comment réagit style sur place
bien pour l'instant il ya vraiment une
extrême chaleur une grande solidarité
beaucoup de gens ont proposé de recevoir
des ukrainiens même s'il ne les
connaissent pas il ya bien sûr une
importante collecte de dons il ya aussi
une association qui s'est formée
moldavie pour la paix et qui aujourd'hui
répond aux ordres du ministère de
l'intérieur et aide à coordonner cette
importante infrastructure qui est qui
est mise en place pour gérer le flux des
réfugiés donc pour l'instant il ya une
grande solidarité encore une fois
beaucoup me rappelle qu'ils sont de
toute façon frère et surtout les
moldaves craignent d'avoir un jour
bientôt peut-être un vivre la même chose
puisqu'ils ont eux aussi un territoire
séparatiste en moldavie la transnistrie
proche de la frontière ukrainienne donc
ils savent qu'ils auront peut-être
bientôt réfugiés eux-mêmes
céline schmitt sur la moldavie
européenne mais précisément sur la
moldavie on a entendu au rien de verdi
dire que c'est un pays de transit est
effectivement plus de 50% des réfugiés
qui arrivent en moldavie n'y reste pas
beaucoup ont notamment en roumanie
poursuivre leur route quoi qu'il en soit
ce petit pays est confronté à un afflux
massif c'est l'un des plus pauvres de la
région comment est ce qu'il peut faire
face à cet afflux oui alors la moldavie
a besoin soutient parce qu'effectivement
comme vous le disiez ils ont fait preuve
de beaucoup de générosité
leurs frontières sont ouvertes les
réfugiés arrivent donc il ya différentes
choses à faire il faut soutenir la
moldavie pour apporter une aide
d'urgence c'est crucial dans un premier
temps l'aide d'urgence c'est-à-dire tout
ce qui est élémentaire des couvertures
en plein hiver des kits pour les enfants
parce qu'il ya beaucoup d'enfants qui
arrive de l'hébergement d'urgence donc
donc c'est une chose mais aussi ce qu'on
a mis en place maintenant on a soutenu
en fait les autorités moldaves et de
roumanie avec l'om notamment pour mettre
en place aussi des débuts sans fête des
transports pour que les personnes
puissent se rendre ensuite en roumanie
est ce que il ya le risque d'une
moldavie qui deviendrait isolé parce
qu'il faut rappeler qu'elle n'est ni
membre de l'union européenne ni membre
de l'otan l'acheminement de l'aide peut
être rendue plus complexe pour ces
raisons là il ya de l'aide qui arrivent
de différents pays européens où elle
sert aussi on envoyé en fait de l'aide
par des cargos justement d'être de
première nécessité mais ensuite il ya
aussi eu il ya un engagement qui est en
train de se mettre en place il vous
l'avez peut-être entendu la france qui a
annoncé
relocaliser en tout cas leur intention
de relocaliser des réfugiés qui arrivent
en moldavie d'autres pays européens
aussi qu'ils ont fait cette annonce en
coordination avec la commission
européenne effectivement ça fait aussi
partie du soutien qui est nécessaire
donc soutenir les pays dans la réponse
d'urgence à la réponse pour la
protection de l'enfance pour donner la
bonne information n'en a pas parlé
encore mais c'est crucial aussi pour
protéger des risques donner la bonne
information aux personnes sur leurs
droits quand il arrive dans un pays mais
ensuite aussi qu'il y ait un partage de
responsabilités et dont est notamment en
prenant en compte les personnes les plus
vulnérables qui ont besoin de soutien et
peut-être un point que je voudrais
ajouter par rapport à ça sur ce qu'on
met en place aussi parce que on parle
des aides d'urgence on a vu qu'il ya
beaucoup de générosité de dons aussi qui
ont été faits nous en plus de ça on met
en place aussi une aide en fait de
transfert de petites sommes en cache en
fait pour aider les personnes pour
qu'elles puissent décider elle-même en
fait de quels sont leurs besoins
élémentaires
donc c'est on met en place en fait ces
systèmes là en moldavie mais aussi par
exemple en pologne pour soutenir les
personnes à faire face à leurs besoins
essentiels en fait le petit ça vous
surprend une telle solidarité non pas du
tout européenne non pas du tout on
attendrait même plus que bien évidemment
nous c'est toujours le cas on a beaucoup
parlé tout de même de la différence de
traitement entre par exemple les
ukrainiens et d'autres réfugiés les
réfugiés syriens par exemple l'accueil
est ce qu'il est à géométrie variable
manifestement oui manifestement oui nous
considérons certainement les ukrainiens
comme étant très proches comme étant nos
voisins voire nos cousins éventuellement
sur le plan culturel sur le plan
spirituel du rêve nous et c'est bien
évidemment par rapport aux syriens il
suffit de se rappeler la crise
migratoire de 2015 2016 si la vie des
syriens le comportement que nous avons
pu avoir vous évoquez la moldavie puis
je rappeler quand même 4 % de la
population c'est 20 % pour ce qui
concerne le liban
de sa population qui est syrienne je
vois pas de la jordanie et même que ce
qui concerne la turquie où ils sont
quatre millions de réfugiés en syrie et
quand erdogan a eu marre d'en avoir
autant il a et voyant que les
occidentaux ne faisait rien il a ouvert
son sa frontière il y en a en 2015 2016
y en a un million cinq qui sont arrivés
et qui a failli faire exploser
complètement l'europe et heureusement
que madame merkel était là pour prendre
les 800000 que personne ne voulait donc
c'est différent bien sûr c'est
manifestement différents bien sûr que
c'est très différent irena car pas bon
comment vous réagissez qu'envoyer
justement cette solidarité européenne
qui s'organisent pour accueillir les
réfugiés d'ukrainiens important pour
nous on se sent pas seul comme ça
c'était c'est vraiment c'est quelque
chose qui réchauffe le coeur quand on
vois pas ce que nous on a commencé nos
initiatives voilà privé entre les
ukrainiens de l'étranger au tout début
pour faire les plateformes comme charles
x ukraine ça c'est qu'on les
particuliers ils proposent leur logement
leur aide et les autres ça marche comme
booking com pour les réfugiés et il ya
beaucoup d'être tout le monde demande
qu'est-ce que je peux faire lors l'a
déjà j'étais au centre au centre mes
enfants font leurs activités il y aura
le point de collecte de la part de la
mairie de notre arrondissement
c'est très important surtout ça me
surprend dans une bonne manière en fait
parce que là finalement c'est très
chaleureux c'est très humain mais là
c'est encore une fois ça montre que les
valeurs sont présentes la valeur des
sols solidarité le prix de vie humain
c'est très important maintenant parce
qu' on essaie et surtout faut comprendre
si on arrête la guerre nous prennent si
on étouffe là bas ça va pas se propager
après en europe est là surtout le
voulait on va pouvoir parler de tchéquie
oui mais là je voulais juste dire que
c'est super bien on organisait là bas
les gens arrivent dans les centres des
ce que j'ai des bénévoles qui m'écrivent
des bénévoles de cech
c'est très organisés dans les centres
ils reçoivent déjà l'assurance médicale
et ils peuvent s'inscrire sur le marché
de travail donc là c'est très important
parce qu'il faut voir que les ukrainiens
sont assez bien qualifiés donc ce sont
les gens avec la plupart elles ont les
études complet l'éducation qui est très
bonne ils sont très faciles à adopter
les miennes qui sont chez moi déjà ils
ont appris un peu de français dans trois
jours qu'il reste chez moi donc ça
commence il faut vraiment établir la
possibilité de travailler parce que
personne ne veut rester sur l'aide
sociale on a tous quitté notre notre vie
qui était plutôt belles toutes ôtées
bien arrangé chez nous donc là il faut
ça si on arrive à mettre en place ce
moment ce sera nickel mais en plus
surtout il faut comprendre que tous les
ukrainiens aspire beaucoup à revenir au
plus vite possible chez nous dès que de
que ce sera fini on va évoquer
évidemment la question du long terme
dans cette émission n'oubliez pas que
vous pouvez nous nous écrire sur twitter
on relaye vos questions sur justement
l'afflux de réfugiés c'est une question
pour vous raphaël pythie ndèye farhi
mata qui demandent quelle aide est
apportée aux africains qui sont bloqués
en ukraine justement je voulais prendre
à prendre à ce sujet j'étais donc au
centre le centre de secours qui est un
centre de secours au niveau du poste
médical poste-frontière de medica qui
est tenu par les sauveteurs sans
frontières qu'ils sont israéliens qui
ont mis en place un dispositif d'accueil
et de prise en charge bien évidemment
ils ont des ils ont bien vu que le
traitement n'était pas est identique
entre les étrangers d'origine africaine
et autres malheureusement et la
population ukrainienne qui sortaient les
ukrainiens les rejeter les empêcher de
monter dans les bus etc ils sont venus à
pied ils ont été bastonnés wrap etc ils
ont été pris en charge justement sur le
plan sanitaire par ces sauveteurs sans
frontières le comportement de la part
d'un certain nombre de populations qui
fuient y ait
rejeté tous les étrangers qui ensuite en
arrivant au poste frontière anti mis
dans des centres de détention centre de
détention et non pas dans un centre
d'hébergement et il fallait que leur
consulat vienne les chercher et les
amène dans leur pays donc conclusion le
traitement des africains à une
différente africains et des autres
étrangers en particulier mais a ajouté
que la ligne largo téléphonique le
dispositif était mise en place tout de
suite par le ministère des affaires
étrangères craignant qu'ils aidaient
exactement aux étudiants d'origine
étrangère pour sortir je crois qu'au
tout début il y avait ces embuscades
parce que les ukrainiens normalement ils
ont droit de voyager sans visa et c'est
pas le cas de tous les pays africains et
après bien sûr dès que leur gouvernement
réagit leur ambassade tout ça était
facilitée et moi je connais aussi
beaucoup beaucoup de bénévoles
ukrainiens qui ont aidé les étudiants
africaine de sortir donc là c'est y
avait des actions positives aussi la
république tchèque en tout cas vous le
disais bien c'est le deuxième pays
d'accueil des réfugiés d'ukrainiens la
communauté ukrainienne est la première
communauté étrangère présente dans ce
pays prague devient vous allez le voir
un point de passage pour les ukrainiens
et sa gare un véritable centre
névralgique reportage sur place de notre
correspondant alexis à rosenberg
à la gare de prague il y a ceux qui
rentrent en ukraine comme natalia grâce
à ce train humanitaire affrété par une
compagnie tchèque moi j'ai mon mari est
déjà rentré se battre et moi je pars
rejoindra dmitro mes trois enfants et
les grands parents quelques hommes aussi
prennent ce train pour rentrer combattre
mais préfère ne pas révéler leur
identité
direction la frontière entre la pologne
et l'ukraine avec des niais comme chef
de bord gloser en plus de la nourriture
et des boissons nous avons aussi très
souvent des wagons cargo pour le
transport de l'aide humanitaire à
quelques mètres de là sur un autre quai
vient d'arriver un train en provenance
de la frontière entre la slovaquie et
l'ukraine à son bord des dizaines de
femmes et d'enfants dont jamal
les bombardements et combats sont
quotidiens on va en suisse où des genres
proposé de nous était la gare c'est con
on était bon on la syrie ont vraiment
c'est bon
pour ces étudiants marocains arrivée de
kharkiv encore sous le choc prague n'est
qu'une étape vers le retour à la maison
oui on attendait un train pour repartir
en allemagne
je peux passer encore en france
après
environ deux cent mille personnes sont
déjà arrivées d'ukraine en république
tchèque ces deux dernières semaines la
population et les autorités de chèques
font preuve d'une grande solidarité avec
ces nouveaux arrivants qui sont aidés
par des volontaires comme daniel
sinclair âge et on lui dit que c'est mon
premier jour et je suis très content
qu'il y ait autant dead et
l'infrastructure en place ici pour
accueillir tous ces gens épuisés qui fit
la guerre la gare centrale de prague se
prépare à l'arrivée de nombreux autres
personnes déplacées le ministre tchèque
de l'intérieur annonce déjà jusqu'à 450
mille réfugiés d'ukraine dans le pays
céline schmitt voilà en mettant un
public tchèque précédemment en pologne
ce sont les deux pays qui accueille le
plus de réfugiés ukrainien est ce qu'on
sait qu'ils seront ou en d'autres mots
est ce qu'on arrive à tracer déjà la
route des réfugiés d'ukrainiens alors ce
qu'on sait c'est que parmi les personnes
qui ont les réfugiés qui sont arrivés au
début les personnes allait surtout dans
vers des pays où ils avaient de la
famille des connaissances un réseau donc
il ya certains pays en europe où il ya
une diaspora plus importante et donc les
réfugiés s'y dirige mais ce qu'on va
certainement voir aussi c'est des
personnes qui vont arriver et qui n'ont
pas de famille qui n'ont pas de
connexion en europe et c'est là aussi où
il faut prendre ça en compte par rapport
à l'accueil justement et organiser
l'accueil des personnes qui n'auront pas
de famille et donc seront aussi plus
vulnérables et c'est là justement que
cette question dont je vous parlais de
l'accès à la bonne information et est
crucial et ça fait partie des premières
choses sur lesquelles nous on a en a
travaillé qui est peut-être
effectivement moins visibles mais il
était crucial en fait que très
rapidement les personnes puissent avoir
accès dans leur langue aux informations
sur quels sont leurs obligations qu'est
ce que ça veut dire la protection
temporaire parce que c'est aussi un
moyen de limiter les risques de violence
et d'exploitation des risques de trafic
d'enfants mais voilà et limiter les
risques de trafic justement donc il ya
ces informations et donc on a créé des
sites web qui s'appelle elles pointent
une hache r qu'on a décliné dans les
différents pays avec des informations
traduite mais aussi on travaille avec
des partenaires qui développent aussi
des informations justement pour prévenir
les risques de traite et de trafic quel
comportement adopter en fait pour pour
ne pas devenir des victimes et donc oui
c'est des sujets qui sont très
importantes aussi pour protéger les
personnes que je transmets ça aux
ukrainiens parce qu'il ya énormément des
jeunes femmes il ya des enfants non
accompagnés et donc là on entend déjà
qu'il ya des gens mal intentionnés les
réseaux mafieux qui se forment pour
faire voilà et s'il ya toujours les gens
qui essayent de son profiter mais c'est
horrible c'est l'horreur et après pour
la solitude oui exactement ça aussi je
puisse que j'ai eus karina moi j'ai
toujours j'essaie de sortir de cette
statistique les vraies histoires
humaines excusez moi ça c'est l'habitude
d'écrivain mais il me dit je me sens
assez seul malgré toute cette solidarité
je me sens seul je suis à prague et
parfois je suis gêné par toute cette
aide qui m'a apporté juste parce que je
sais qu'il ya des gens qui en qu'il
manque plus que moi après lille et la
première le premier jour je pleurais
parce que moi je suis venu avec deux
chats et rien que voir la nourriture
qu'ils étaient amenés par les tchèques
pour aider à mécha donc ça m'a été
trompés mieux je pleurais raphaël quitté
l'europe peut-elle tenir
c'est un vrai problème dans le prix
médian on est dans cet élan de
solidarité très important et après on va
se confronter un véritable problème qui
est la prise en charge de ces millions
de personnes et j'ai tout à craindre de
penser quand on regarde ce qui s'est
passé en syrie que l'on va que poutine
va instrumentaliser ce les réfugiés
c'est à dire les pousser à partir de
maintenir les corridors ça il a commencé
à le faire en disant je bomba mais je
laisse les corridors les populations qui
veulent sortir peuvent sortir et il va
nous envoyer le maximum de personnes on
peut penser que sur 40 millions il peut
y avoir huit dix millions de dhs
ukrainien qui vont partir vers l'europe
je rappelle qu'en syrie ils sont 7
millions à être sortis du pays et à
l'intérieur du pays il y a 6 millions de
personnes déplacées à l'intérieur du
pays encore aujourd'hui demain la syrie
ces onze ans de guerre les craignent une
démobilisation de l'opinion justement
fur et à mesure du temps qui passe
absolument absolument cette générosité
aura ses limites dès lors qu'elle va
poser des problèmes justement de donner
du travail cette population la prise en
charge sanitaire sociale de ces
populations va finir par poser des
problèmes sur le plan économique bien
évidemment sur le plan de la recherche
du travail sur le plan du logement
social qu'il faudra mettre à disposition
nous avons une certaine tension sur le
logement social en france comment
pourrons-nous alors même que déjà des
syriens sont maintenus dans les centres
d'hébergement alors même qu'ils ont
obtenu leur statut de réfugié ils ne
sortent pas des centres d'hébergement
parce qu'il n'ya pas de logements
sociaux et 50% de nos cada de nos
centres d'hébergement en france en
occupés par des gens qui ont un statut
de réfugié et qui ne peuvent pas sortir
parce qu'ils ne trouvent pas du travail
et parce qu'il n'ya pas de logements
sociaux à leurs données pour finir cette
guerre le plus vite possible mais voilà
pour éviter tout stress que ce non pas
leur affaire une pythie ce sont des
choses auxquelles vous pensez qu'il
utilise ne le fait que voilà toutes ces
questions des réfugiés grenelle comme ça
tombe un peu dans l'oubli avec une
guerre qui durerait oui on a peur de ça
mais c'est pour ça que les premières se
bat pour ne pas tourner pas laisser
errer les choses pareilles c'est pour ça
qu'on continue à supplée a demandé voilà
si c'est pas l'exclusion aérienne au
moins les systèmes de protections
solaires qui en ce moment vont sauver
les vies des civils qui sont encerclées
arqiva mario paul tous ces millions tous
ces milliers de femmes et d enfants nos
claque quand on parle aujourd'hui de
deux se donnent deux d envoi des armes
on parle plutôt d aide humanitaire parce
que c'est ça qui va qui va sauver les
8es vous croyez en les capacités de
l'europe se tenir oui confiance mais je
fais confiance non là je fais confiance
qu'il faut vraiment aux contre-attaqués
qu'il faut se protéger que ça se trouve
que les ukrainiennes puisse gagner cette
guerre qu'il puisse battre l'ennemi est
comme ça tous ces gens vont réunir chez
eux personne ne veut partir ça je vous
assure même accueil à présent leslie
carretero journaliste pour le site info
migrants qui appartient au même groupe
que france 24 et rfi bonsoir islip vous
avez passé plusieurs jours en roumanie
vous êtes rentré dimanche dernier
précisément vous étiez à la frontière
avec l'ukraine à sir est dans la ville
de siret vous avez été marqué ma vie dit
par un mouvement de solidarité très fort
oui alors on en a un peu parlé autour
des tables mais c'est vrai que quand je
suis arrivé à la frontière j'ai été
assez impressionné par ce mouvement de
personnes et beaucoup de citoyens en
fait volontaire qui sont venus
spontanément apporté leur aide donc soit
distribué de la nourriture faire la
traduction
même accueillir des personnes chez eux
ce qui m'a le plus impressionné c'est de
voir les autorités en fait qui ont eux
aussi participer à l'effort elle aussi
participer à l'effort pardon j'ai
notamment vu des pompiers ou des
policiers tirer eux mêmes les valises
des déplacés ukrainiens et les orienter
vers des cars vers des centres
d'hébergement d'urgence ou vers des
voitures vers des citoyens et c'est
quelque chose que l'on ne voit pas
souvent nous en tant que journaliste
alors justement vous êtes juriste
spécialiste de ces questions de
migration vous suivez pour info migrants
ces dossiers là depuis des années et
alors on est quoi ce qu'on a dit
précédemment dans l'émission vous avez
le sentiment qu'il ya une différence de
traitement selon les populations ce qu
on pourrait appeler ça un deux poids
deux mesures oui alors c'est vrai que
pour nous journalistes d'infos migrants
qui comme vous le dites travaillons sur
le sujet depuis longtemps on n'a jamais
vu un tel accueil il ya toujours eu des
ong des citoyens qui se portaient
volontaires mais alors que les autorités
se demandent si accueillante c'est très
très rare notamment dans ces pays là
je rappelle que la hongrie qui fait
partie donc des trois des trois pays
européens en tout cas qui accueille le
plus de personnes a été condamné à
plusieurs reprises par la courbe de
cours européennes pardon de
des droits de l'homme pour mauvais
traitements envers les demandeurs
d'asile et également pour avoir enfermé
des demandeurs d'asile dans des centres
dans des centres fermés le dernier
jugement date de novembre 2021 donc
c'est encore très récent la pologne
aussi actuellement encore à la frontière
avec la biélorussie il ya des centaines
et des milliers personnes qui sont
refoulés principalement des personnes
qui viennent du moyen-orient et qui sont
renvoyés de manière très violente côté
biélorusse qu'ils ne peuvent même pas de
déposer l'asile nous on a eu des
témoignages de gens qui nous racontent
qu'ils ont été frappés et qu'ils ont
reçues qui ont reçu des coups et
lorsqu'il arriva à pénétrer enfin sur le
sol pwner polonais après avoir passé des
heures des jours dans la fronti dans la
forêt environnante à se cacher et bien
là ils sont encore une fois parqués dans
des centres dans des centres fermés ils
ne peuvent pas en sortir et ça peut
durer plusieurs mois alors la roumanie
c'est un peu moins catastrophique si je
peux dire ça comme ça mais moi j'ai
encore eu un témoignage la semaine fin
l'année dernière par nom d'un sénégalais
qui me racontait qu'il avait essayé de
passer la frontière depuis la serbie et
qu'ils avaient été violentés par les
gardes-frontière roumain qui lui avait
volé ses affaires et tu lui as qu'il
avait aussi renvoyé manu militari côté
serbe sens là aussi avoir pu déposer
l'asie donc en effet selon là là où on
arrive cc c'est plus compliqué vous
l'avouerez de la roumanie la pologne la
biélorussie mes parents est ce qu'en
france aussi on observe ces différences
de traitement parce qu'un avis et les
afflux de réfugiés et craignant on va en
parler en france oui il ya des afflux
d'autres personnes aussi en france on
parle beaucoup du crâne en ce moment
mais
la france alors là j'ai vu que pour
préparer et coordonner l'arrivée des
ukrainiens là le gouvernement a mis en
place une cellule de crise
interministérielle
ils ont ouvert une plate forme où chaque
citoyen français peut s'inscrire pour
héberger un ukrainien chez lui ils ont
ouvert des places d'hébergement
supplémentaires là encore c'est des
choses qu'on ne voit pas on n'a pas vu
ça pendant la guerre en syrie on n'a pas
vu ça encore il ya très peu de temps en
afghanistan avec l'afghanistan cet été
où il ya quand même la reprise du
pouvoir par les talibans en afghanistan
il ya eu un flot un port important de
migrants et de réfugiés selon
l'appellation qu'on veut dire qu'on veut
bien leur donner alors certes à cette
époque là la france a accueilli 3000
afghans mais il ya encore des gens qui
sont arrivés après en fait et qui sont
actuellement dans les rues de paris et
qui n'ont aucune aide on peut aussi
parler de calais où là aussi il ya des
afghans il ya des soudanais il ya des
syriens il ya des gens qui peuvent
prétendre au statut de réfugié et akalé
là aussi il ya une grosse différence on
a vu la maire de calais natacha bouchart
qui accueille en grande pompe des
réfugiés ukrainien qui lui ouvre des
hébergements qui a même réservé des des
restaurants pour eux alors qu'à côté il
ya des personnes qui sont qui sont dans
la rue dans les campements informels je
rappelle quand même que natacha bouchart
la maire de calais a interdit les
distributions de nourriture aux exilés
dans la ville par les ong non mandatés
par l'état avec l'aide de la préfecture
c'est quand même une mère qui a posé des
rochers a mis des arceaux de vélo qui a
déboisé des terrains où étaient
restés les personnes et tout ça pour
éviter des campements se reforme alors à
calais la semaine dernière les
associations me disais que est dénoncé
clairement une logique raciste et elle
réfléchissait à porter plainte contre la
mairie mais aussi contre l'état pour
pour discrimination
merci les six en tout cas le
gouvernement français anticipe l'arrivée
possible de cent mille réfugiés
ukrainien dans les prochaines semaines
reportage thibault jean-pierre
j'en prends pas trop comme ça la
prochaine fois je vous en demande vous
dirai pas lui il est bien mais on va
leur donner
son succès est total comme tous les
jours de marché les élans de générosité
se multiplient sa cagnotte est déjà
pleine laurent est obligés de refuser
des aides je vois bien depuis tout à
l'heure si vous aidez freiné parce que
ils veulent me donner encore me donner
encore me donner aujourd'hui non non
attendez laissez moi digérer alors après
il ya d'autres canaux mes enfants
concernés et les clients n'hésitent pas
à mettre la main à la poche ben on peut
que saluer ce genre d'action quoi et
puis aidé à la mesure des moyens chacun
quoi aujourd'hui j'ai ramené des
affaires de bébé d'à nourriture un peu
d'argent pour ce deuxième voyage en
pologne toute la famille de laurent est
impliqué au dépôt sa femme virginie tri
des vêtements et appréhendent de laisser
partir son jeune fils dans cette
aventure
ça c'est un sujet sensible en voilà il
va avoir 17 ans mardi donc il va passer
son adversaire sur la route après il est
hyper hyper impliqué noie ses
logisticiens de tout bon en fait c'est
ce qu'il faudrait c'est ordre sont
claires objectif amener le convoi à bon
port noah en classe de première est
heureux de faire partie du voyage en
fait je voulais y aller parce que je me
dis mon cerveau je ferai part toutes les
palettes et tout mais moi je veux voir
comment ça se passe là bas parce que je
vois ça m'intrigue en fait
la semaine dernière après avoir livré
l'aide le convoi a fait le trajet du
retour avec trois familles chrétiennes à
son bord voir le soulagement de ces
réfugiés étaient leur arrivée en france
donne de la force à laurent j'étais
tellement content d'avoir réussi cette
double mission de la porte d'apport
logistique et de rapatriement de deux
personnes en demande d'évacuation des
zones de conflit que finalement la
fatigue qui n'oublie que
cinquante et une heure de voyage
attendent laurent hénault à leur point
de chute en pologne et le centre
logistique de medica depuis le début du
conflit ce poste frontière a déjà vu
passer près de quatre cent mille
réfugiés ukrainien
céline schmitt plus de 13500 ukrainiens
sont déjà arrivés en france la france
peut-elle accueillir cent mille réfugiés
oui c'est ce que c'est c'est ce qui a
été annoncé et en fait les autorités
nationales sont en contact avec les
préfectures les élus locaux pour
identifier des lieux des centres on
pourrait être accueilli les réfugiés il
ya une mobilisation vraiment au niveau
national aussi on voit beaucoup de
villes qui se mobilisent ont fait partie
des changes aussi avec les villes
justement qui se mobilisent qu'ils ont
des questions qu'ils veulent savoir
comment se mobiliser et c'est très bien
qui est cette mobilisation à tous les
niveaux en fait parce que c'est c'est
grâce à cette mobilisation finalement de
toute la société de tous les acteurs de
la société on n'a pas parlé des
entreprises encore mais les entreprises
aux entreprises de danseuses se
mobilisent aussi les entreprises
françaises se mobilisent aussi oui et
c'est justement la mobilisation de ces
différents acteurs qui va permettre
l'accueil parce qu'on le disait il ya
l'accueil d'urgence pia cet
accompagnement sur le long terme
l'accompagnement sur le long terme c'est
aussi l'accès à l'emploi et donc
effectivement que les entreprises
s'impliquent c'est très important aussi
une quels sont les obstacles parce que
nous même beaucoup alors les obstacles
il y as besoin d'un accompagnement
spécifique de personnes qui sont qui ont
fui la guerre parce qu'elles sont
traumatisés et donc je veux pas parler
d'un obstacle mais peut-on être un point
d'attention vraiment porter l'attention
sur l'accompagnement dont les les
personnes ont besoin l'accompagnement
pour que les enfants puissent aller à
l'école l'obstacle on peut être la
langue justement donc le besoin d'avoir
des interprètes de pouvoir communiquer
avec les personnes dans leur langue donc
tout ça c'est des points d'attention
qu'il faut adresser en fait il doit y
avoir un encadrement par exemple j'ai lu
qu'il y avait vingt mille propositions
d'hébergement citoyens en france donc
fort élan de solidarité mais ce n'est
pas si simple de recevoir des familles
j'imagine une fois d'encadrement
complètement alors bien sûr cette
solidarité elle est formidable et et
elle doit être accueillie mais bien sur
l'hébergement citoyen doit aussi être
encadré surtout si l'hébergement
citoyens et plus le que simplement les
premiers jours en fait de l'accueil mais
c'est ce que ce que met en place aussi
ce que mettre en place les autorités
avec une plate forme justement qui a été
créé pour mettre un lien les personnes
qui souhaitent accueillir les personnes
qui ont besoin d'être accueillis et en
organisant un accompagnement des
familles qui accueillent et ça c'est
extrêmement important parce que les
réfugiés qui arrivent ont besoin d'être
accompagnés elles ont besoin d'un
accompagnement social un accompagnement
dans dans les démarches et donc c'est ce
travail ensemble qui permet justement
qui est un bon accueil les citoyens les
autorités les entreprises des villes
alors ça c'est l'espoir par contre ce
qui est beaucoup moins positifs raphaël
pythie c'est cette logique à deux
vitesses que vous avez évoqué que leslie
carretero évoqué qui toucherait aussi la
france d'entendre ce qui se passe à
calais est ce que il ya le risque
finalement aujourd'hui en france
également d'une priorité de réfugiés par
rapport à d'autres priorités les
ukrainiens par rapport aux autres oui
bien sûr c'est ce qu'il est en train de
se passer d'ailleurs c'est évident il ya
les laissés pour compte maintenant
qu'ils sont les citoyens les afghans et
d'autres populations qui fuient ont fuit
la violence quel thème du moyen orient
du yémen où d'ailleurs bien évidemment
et que maintenant tout se tourner la
priorité vient justement vers les
ukrainiens qui obtiennent immédiatement
une protection subsidiaire temporaire
ils vont l'obtenir sans avoir à déposer
de dossier si vous voulez hein
visuellement comme sont obligés de le
faire les autres etc rentrer dans un
processus qui va prendre un an ou deux
ans les ukrainiens vont obtenir d'emblée
cette protection subsidiaire et pourront
donc obtenir les droits qui vont avec
c'est à dire rentrer dans le droit
commun français obtiendront une
allocation d' aide aux demandeurs
d'asile qui est la leur mais comme ils
sont pas demandeurs d'asile ils ont le
droit de travailler immédiatement ils
ont le droit de rentrer dans le droit
commun français avec la possibilité de
se faire soigner etc c'est ce qui est en
train de se passer bien évidemment je
voudrais rappeler quand même que
l'instrumentalisation qui va être faite
par poutine qui va faire en sorte de
nous envoyer vers nous le maximum de la
population ukrainienne qui voudra
pousser mais on ira vers 7 8 9 ou 10
millions de personnes il faut la
négocier non pas le maintien des
territoires mais obtenir ce que erdogan
avait réussi à obtenir puisqu'il avait 4
millions c'est à dire des zones de
désescalade de la violence à l'intérieur
de la syrie et il y avait une 82 d
escalade de la violence qui avait été
ouverte en syrie et dans lesquels
le l'onu du hcr approvisionner
directement par des convois humanitaires
c'était des corridors humanitaires y en
avait quatre corridors humanitaires qui
permettait justement l'approvisionnement
de cette population et qui restait en
syrie justement pour qu'elle ne sorte
pas et aujourd'hui sous la pression
russe il ne reste plus qu'un seul
corridor humanitaire
renouvelable tous les six mois
maintenant les autres enfermé il reste
qu'on appelle la zone de libre où vous
avez deux millions huit cent mille
déplacés qui sont là et une population
globale de 4 millions 200 mille
directement
nécessitent une aide humanitaire
immédiat est constant il ya environ 1000
camions de l'ue acr qui rentrent pas par
ce corridor humanitaire dans la zone des
idées pour les approvisionner que
poutine voudrait bien voir fermer
certainement donc ce qu'il faut négocier
maintenant avec poutine c'est justement
cela c'est à dire l'ouverture de zones
de protection avec non survol aérien et
une protection servent pour porte pour
que les populations a directement dans
cette zone et que les ong puissent
intervenir que de la chair puisse
intervenir dans ces zones de désescalade
de la violence j'ai une autre question
puisqu'on parle de lui en parler de la
france vous concernant
parce que tous les candidats ou presque
à la présidentielle en france de
l'extrême gauche à l'extrême droite
s'accordent pour dire qu'il faut
accueillir les réfugiés ce qui semble un
son de cloche à c'est assez nouveau les
refuges et craignent un évidemment
demain mardi des ong pour lesquels vous
travaillez lui au ssm voilà l'union des
organisations de secours et soins
médicaux lance un plaidoyer à tous ces
candidats qu'est ce que vous leur dites
et bien justement ce durant onze années
les crimes contre l'humanité les crimes
de guerre la violence faite aux
populations
l'utilisation d'armes interdites par
rapport à cette population la fuite de
ces populations et ses onze années que
la population syrienne et a été
martyrisé onze années
qu'est-ce qu'on fait nos politiques
jusqu à présent qu est ce qu a fait le
monde occidental jusqu'à présent pour
empêcher cette violence contre cette
population qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait est
ce qu il est vrai ils vendent en être de
même pour l'ukraine est-ce qu'il va
enlève est-ce que nous allons nous
contenter simplement d'accueillir les
réfugiés je vous les interpellés de
cette manière là mais c'est bien ça que
comptez vous faire que comptez-vous
faire par rapport à cela que comptez
vous faire contre les crimes contre
l'humanité qui vont être là qu'est ce
que vous comptez faire justement pour
débloquer des fonds d'urgence pour aider
ces populations
qu'est ce que vous comptez faire
justement pour empêcher la destruction
des hôpitaux je vous rappelle que deux
hôpitaux ont déjà été détruites par les
russes qu'est ce que vous comptez faire
justement pour savoir ces zones de
désescalade de la violence qu est ce que
vous comptez faire s'il s'agit
simplement à chaque fois de s'apitoyer
sur la situation d'ouvrir son coeur par
rapport et c'est çà ne cessa n'est pas
une solution
l'action humanitaire la partie russe
humanitaire l'action politique
appartient aux politiques et l'action
politique ne veut pas se contenter de
faire de l'action humanitaire pour ce 2
pour se crédibiliser ça c'est clair à
chacun son travail à cause justement de
cette situation qui fait que nos
politiques sont incapables de trouver
des solutions politiques savez vous
qu'il ya 70 millions de personnes dans
le monde qui sont sous des tentes depuis
1945 70 millions je pars en parlant des
palestiniens et d'autres où des
soudanais ou autre c'est à dire qu'on
est incapable aujourd'hui de trouver des
solutions politiques alors on se
contente d'avoir de remplacer sa part
des actions humanitaires l'humanitaire
appartient aux humanitaires et les ong
sont là pour ça et la solidarité
internationale joue très bien les gens
ont bon coeur aux politiques de trouver
des solutions politiques et on accorde
pas vrai peut-être réagir justement à ce
que vient de dire a failli péter oui ça
c'est très dur moi je sais c'est une
idée brillante gleizes les la zone de
conflit d escalader sauf que poutine
c'est un menteur même s'il va dire oui
d'accord je suis après il va dire que ce
sont les forces ukrainienne cavs ont
bombardé les convois humanitaires et les
convois et où il va dire c'est toujours
comme ça c'est ça c'est ça qui est
problématique mais je suis complètement
d'accord qu'il faut vraiment sécuriser
les zones parce que encore une fois les
ukrainiennes quittent pas leur payer de
leur propre gré tout le monde avait sa
vie établie là bas et donc comme comme
j'ai déjà dit on compte sur l'aide pour
arrêter cette guerre pour pour arrêter
poutine un retour justement en pologne
où l'afflux des réfugiés bien sûr va se
poursuivre on va trouver à nouveau notre
envoyé spécial emmanuel chaze emmanuel
il y à une gestion de l'urgence à on l'a
vu et puis il ya une gestion de la
situation dans la durée et les besoins
de financement sont ils importants en
pologne
oui c'est vrai que là pour l'instant ça
a été ça a été une gestion plutôt
spontané la pologne a fait du mieux et
fait toujours du mieux qu'elle peut je
vous parlais tout à l'heure des écoles
qui ont été réquisitionnés comme centres
d'hébergement d'urgence jeudi dernier le
parlement polonais a voté une enveloppe
exceptionnelle financière pour tenter de
gérer cette crise humanitaire qui se
déroule dans ces régions frontalières et
pas seulement puisque 10% de ses 1,7
million de réfugiés venus d'ukraine
entrée en pologne se trouve dans la dans
la capitale varsovie donc le
gouvernement polonais a voté cette
enveloppe de 1,6 milliard d'euros pour
répondre aux besoins immédiats pour
gérer immédiatement cette cette crise
humanitaire à ses frontières mais il ya
beaucoup d'interrogations évidemment qui
persiste c'est une réponse à ce qui se
passe présentement à ce qui est en train
de se dérouler alors il ya des il ya des
visas des permis de séjour qui sont
accordés aux réfugiés l'ukrainien de 18
mois j'ai parlé avec des polonais qui me
disaient qu'ils n'étaient pas très
inquiet en fait pour l'intégration des
dans la durée en fait de cette
population ukrainienne en pologne du
fait de cette importante communauté
ukrainienne qui étaient déjà sur place
deux millions de personnes vous en
parlais tout à l'heure mais aussi parce
que la plupart des sites administratifs
ici en pologne sont déjà traduit en
ukrainien donc c'est vrai qu'il ya un
optimisme de ce côté là mais c'est vrai
que forcément cette arrivée massive de
personnes et bien ça va forcément créer
créer un impact économique et c'est bien
pour cela d'ailleurs que les autorités
polonaises et notamment le maire de
varsovie en ont appelé à la communauté
internationale pour soutenir la pologne
dans ce grand effort humanitaire merci
emmanuel emmanuel chaze donc une en
pologne on va tout de suite en moldavie
où là aussi on s'inquiète bien sûr d'un
afflux qui va se poursuivre on retrouve
notre envoyé spécial oriane verdier
oriane la moldavie va avoir aussi besoin
d'un soutien financier
[Applaudissements]
oui parce qu'on veut le début on regarde
particulièrement la ville d'odessa qui
est seulement à 50 km de la frontière
moldave la grosse ville portuaire
d'odessa avec un million d'habitants
donc si l'offensive qu'on en sait
réellement concrètement sur des sacs la
majorité des ukrainiens se tournerait
vers la moldavie je vous parlais d'une
organisation qui semble rouler pour
l'instant à la frontière mais dans ce
cas là il faudra bien sûr arriver à
juguler ce nouveau flux parce qu'il fait
particulièrement froid dans le sud est
de l'ukraine est donc en moldavie soumis
au vent de la mer noire et puis il pas
le port d'odessa c'est aussi beaucoup
d'importation pour pour la moldavie donc
le pays lui même rien faire face à une
difficulté économique
tout aussi d'importer citoyens que pour
aider ces réfugiés enfin si sur le long
terme les ukrainiens présent en moldavie
reste en moldavie eh bien il faudra
arriver à trouver du travail et ici en
moldavie c'est l'un des pays les plus
pauvres de l'europe les moldaves
eux-mêmes me disent à avoir du mal à
trouver du travail et puis bien sûr on
parle d'avenir pour les moldaves
l'avenir c'est potentiellement encore
une fois poutine qui pourraient se
tourner vers la moldavie et dans ce cas
là on part qu'on parlerait d'une toute
autre histoire merci oriane oriane verdi
en direct de la frontière moldave céline
schmitt porte parole du haut
commissariat de l'onu pour les réfugiés
sur la question du financement l'union
européenne a déjà dépensé pour
accueillir ces réfugiés ukrainien plus
d'un milliard d'euros
c'est loin d'être terminé combien de
temps est-ce que ce seront minées peut
continuer à être au vert alors on a fait
nous aussi un appel de fonds d'urgence
justement pour répondre à la situation à
la fois dans les pays voisins qui a
conquis accueille les réfugiés pour
soutenir les autorités mais aussi pour
notre réponse humanitaire en ukraine
donc là aussi ce sont plus d'un milliard
d'euros dont nous avons besoin avec les
autres acteurs humanitaires les autres
agences des nations unies pour à la fois
pouvoir apporter de l'aide humanitaire
essentielle en ukraine là où on peut
avoir un accès humanitaire parce que
c'est aussi très très compliqué pour les
humanitaires les collègues du hcr
actuellement de de travail et
on a pré disposition est prédisposé
pardon des stocks dans le centre l'ouest
du pays on est proche des frontières
aussi vers les pays voisins pour
apporter de l'aide aux personnes qui
attendent très souvent de longues heures
avant de pouvoir traverser et ensuite on
prévoit une réponse dans les pays
voisins avec un chiffre pour l'instant
de planification parce qu'il faut bien
qu'on on planifie en fait l'aide donc le
chiffre de planification qu'on a pour
l'instant ces quatre millions de
réfugiés donc c'est pas une prévision
qu'on fait c'est vraiment un chiffre de
planification et donc c'est sur cette
base là qu'on a fait un appel de fonds
pour pouvoir financer le l'aide
d'urgence ces germes ans ces quatre
millions de réfugiés attendu où vont ils
aller il n'y a pas de plan de
répartition pour le moment sur la table
alors on évoquer le fait y en a beaucoup
qui veulent revenir dans leur pays mais
au ya pas de plan de répartition
peut-être pour ajouter juste un tout
petit point par rapport à ça aussi c'est
important ce que vous disiez nous aussi
c'est ce que nous disent les réfugiés
qui traverse quand on leur demande de
quoi avez vous besoin parce qu'ils
disent à nos collègues on veut que ça
s'arrête on veut rentrer chez nous et je
pense que c'est juste d'importants de
juste dire ça aussi mis ensuite la
protection temporaire permet justement
une possibilité de mouvement en fait une
liberté de circulation des personnes
dans l'union européenne et c'est
important aussi donc les personnes qui
ont des connaissances de la famille
peuvent se diriger vers vers les pays où
ils ont la famille mais il faudra
effectivement réfléchir à l'accueil des
personnes qui vont arriver et qui n'ont
pas de famille est donc là oui c'est
aussi un partage de responsabilités au
niveau européen qui doit être discuté
raphaël
ce qu'on n'a pas encore congrès manar
pas voilà donc parce que exactement j'ai
amené mes réfugiés aux filles ils ont
donné les papiers pour la demande des
îles c'est pas exactement ça donc là je
dis qu'il faut demander la protection
tempérament il faut aller où il faut
s'adresser où c'est la mairie c'est la
préfecture c'est là aussi parce qu'il ya
plein de gens qui demande et pour le
moment j'ai l'impression qu'ils sont un
peu de chaos parce que les autorités
n'ont pas compris très bien qu'est ce
qu'il faut faire il ya une complexité
des mots complexité bureaucratique voilà
donc la cie vous si vous avez la réponse
à ma question je suis prêt non il passé
pour que je vais pas répondre à la place
de l'état mais je peux répondre
effectivement c'est les préfectures qui
veut revoir la tâche en fait d'accorder
la protection temporaire ou là on a pris
beaucoup de temps juste un dernier tour
de table raphaël pythie comment faire
comment aider ces réfugiés concrètement
vous faites partie de cette ong vous
êtes responsable des personnels
soignants et vous voulez justement
développer la formation sur place du
personnel soignant qui font l'amour la
grève des big men impacte directement
les centres urbains donc directement les
hôpitaux civils les hôpitaux civils sont
soumis comme en syrie durant ses onze
années à la fois à la pathologie
chronique à la pathologie aiguë qui
survient etc mais en même temps aux
afflux de victimes qui viennent des
zones de combat et donc ça pose un vrai
problème or ce le personnel soignant
n'est pas fort mais justement la
pathologie de guerre c'est ce que nous
avons fait pendant ces pendant ces onze
années nous avons ouvert quatre centres
de formation formé à la fois les
secouristes formés des médecins les
infirmiers les sages femmes les
chirurgiens a assisté la pathologie de
guerre y compris à au chimique bien
évidemment parce qu'il ya un risque
maintenant ça c'est votre projet et ça
c'est notre projet c'est d'ouvrir un
centre de formation à l'intérieur de la
syrie certainement aux alentours de
autour de l'ukraine en hiver et à kiev
mais il reinacker pas le ton est grave
ce soir mais est ce que vous arrivez à
rester optimiste oui comme tous les
ukrainiens je crois on essaye là le
montant du maure d'humour voilà
quelqu'un qui a j'aimerais bien vous
traduire quelques blagues et là je reste
optimiste parce que comme cette petite
fille qui hébergeait chez nous m'a ya
des 13 ans où on était super enquête
pour elle pour le premier jour elle
revient et la diva maman à sa maman et à
raphaël et il m'a montré tous les gars
ont montré comment qu'est-ce qu'il faut
prendre dans la quartier neto donc là on
est vraiment très très ému et
et donc là vraiment je crois beaucoup au
new new new money humanité et que la fin
des guerres sert à beaucoup plus proche
qu'on en pense seni schmidt à un mot sur
ce qu'on peut faire on une minute bien
sûr je pense que ce qui est important
c'est que tout le monde peut s'engager
on l'a dit les citoyens les entreprises
les villes et c'est extrêmement
important que tous s'engagent pour
apporter une réponse mais on l'a évoqué
aussi et je voulais dire aussi ne pas
oublier les autres crise parce
qu'effectivement il ya 84 millions de
personnes dans le monde qui sont
déracinées à cause de persécutions à
cause de la violence beaucoup à
l'intérieur de leur propre pays mais 26
millions sont des réfugiés des crises
qui continue notre commissaire filippo
grandi et justement actuellement en
afghanistan pour suivre la situation
là-bas aussi donc n'oublions pas les
réfugiés et que cette solidarité en fait
soit une solidarité avec les réfugiés de
mes racines du mal céline schmitt merci
beaucoup raphaël petit merci à vous et
grenat car pas merci aux morts aux mains
à zoug où on jouit aussi non et puis
merci à vous tous d'avoir suivi vous
restez avec nous sur france 24 et sur
rfi la sueur
[Musique]
l'actualité du monde vous la suivez en
direct sur france 24 pour
l'approfondissement le commentaire
rendez vous désormais tous les jours
dans on va plus loin les regards croisés
de nos spécialistes il y à l'histoire il
ya le poids de l'histoire si c'est une
question de considération et de libye